I know stats could prove me wrong but I
don't think anyone would argue against
the statement that a lot of modern anime
seems to feature teenagers in some sort
of school comedic school anime has been
a mainstay for as long as I can remember
and it seems they won't be going away
anytime soon animes found a way to look
at school life from different angles
there are a lot of anime that feature
school life but that doesn't mean
they're cut from the same cloth so now
it's time for something different from
the usual content we're taking a look
now at the top ten school comedy anime
[Music]
for this edition of our top ten we start
with teasing master Takagi son this is a
simple anime the story centers on
Nishikawa
a poor boy who finds himself on the
receiving end of endless teasing from
his classmate takagi he vows to get
revenge on his classmate by embarrassing
her but unfortunately for him reprieve
is nowhere in sight after all takagi
knows him inside out and outsmarts him
at every single turn now what it doesn't
have a long overarching plot the show
guarantees ample laughter due to the
creativity and plotting by the main
characters Misha clutter and Takagi
going at each other is a sequence that
you just won't get tired of a second
season is currently airing so be sure to
get your dose of smug Takagi now before
we get on with the video I'd like to
give a shout out to this video sponsor
raid shadow legends for those who don't
know raid shadow legends is a brand-new
collection RPG Gabe has taken the mobile
gaming landscape by storm it has great
graphics strategic gameplay huge boss
fights an amazing storyline and over 400
champions for you to collect and
personally customize personally I mean I
think the game's amazing and I don't
think I've seen too many mobile games
with this level of graphics the other
thing I love about it is that everyone
can find something for themselves some
love collecting characters some all
about the deep storyline in graphics and
I personally am down for combating
against live players but that's just me
so what are you waiting for
go to the video description click on the
special link and you'll instantly get
50,000 silver and a free epic champion
as part of the new player program to
start your journey
at number nine we follow geo story in
monthly girls nozaki kun this anime
revolves around Chiyo Sakura who finally
gathers up the courage to confess to her
crush no Saki to her dismay the
denseness Aki isn't exactly the
brightest when it comes to reciprocating
a girl's feelings furthermore no Saki
turns out to be a popular manga artist
and interprets her confession as wanting
to be his assistant hilarity ensues as
Chiyo gets involved in those are keys
manga work and is introduced to
schoolmates and people with their own
entertaining quirks for me this anime
strong suit is in its characters in its
12 run episode the show never fails to
entertain through its colorful cast so
once you've watched the show I'm certain
you'll find a character you can relate
to and take delight in seeing the
dynamics between the characters as well
as the development of their
relationships
[Music]
number 8 entry shouldn't be a stranger
to a lot of people it's the ever-popular
my teen romantic comedy snafu this anime
star's antisocial teenager Hachi man he
ki gaya he doesn't believe in the joys
of youth and drones on in his cynical
worldview
he gets forced to join a service club
where he gets acquainted with Yukino now
in the last place he actually wants to
be [ __ ] man is thrust straight into
helping other students with their
problems for those of us who've had a
similar phase of cynicism this anime is
probably one of the better
recommendations on the list as it takes
a different perspective from the typical
anime rom-com in lieu of a blossoming
romance with comedy between its
characters snafu focuses on characters
who find it difficult to fit in and in
the case of Hachi man one who rejects
the standardized ideas of the joys of
youth charming yet frank and realistic
characterizes snafu as an anime it also
functions as an interesting commentary
on people with social problems while not
being overly blunt with its messages
[Music]
holding what is it
toaster Corner chat the middle combo
Housing Minister CAI secured a dozen at
number seven we take a look at real-life
erratic ice hockey is a directionless 27
year old man after quitting his job he
encounters a man from the real-life
Research Institute he proposes a
mysterious drug to errata that can
change his appearance to a 17 year old
allowing him to once again enter high
school and have a second go at youth
however he also finds that this makes
him the subject of an experiment and to
add to that high school life doesn't
turn out to be as easy as he envisioned
rewards await him if he completes the
year but if anyone discovers his true
identity all of his memories will be
wiped clean
real life handles a subject that's
likely to pique anyone's interest the
idea of taking yourself back to the past
and living with your superior experience
could have crossed your mind before and
if you're like me one of those people
real life should be an anime for you the
pacing is slow at times but the show has
its moments and is certainly a unique
take on the school anime genre
[Music]
six on the list is action comedy anime
Beelzebub Tatsumi ogres a first year at
the delinquent filled war zone known as
a Shyama hi he's not just any other
first-year student though he's the
school's top fighter evidenced by his
nickname rampaging ogre his worlds
shaken one day when he becomes the
foster parent of the demon king son baby
Beel initially reluctant to raise the
baby that's become attached to him
Olga's mind changes thanks to an
encounter with a demon maid who ends up
acting as baby Bill's mother hijinks
ensue as ogre must now adjust to the
responsibility of raising the future
demon king faced by other demonic forces
juvenile delinquents and the challenges
of highschool life this gargantuan tasks
now a lot more challenging than it
initially sounded if you're up for some
absurd action and a dash of crass humor
in an anime that doesn't take itself too
seriously you might want to give this
show a shot hailing from qurani nichijou
takes its place as number five on the
list among the studio's numerous big
successes such as k-on and Haru II one
can find this hidden gem it's a comedy
that revolves around mio Yuki and my a
trio of high school girls and their
daily antics now while it may seem
simple and unspectacular the show
overall is anything but seeing pure
comedy like nichijou is rare since most
shows claiming to be comedy often have a
plot that glues everything together and
if not they typically have interesting
supernatural aspects to fall back on
good comedy combines a lot of different
elements such as a story that drags you
along or interesting gimmicks in the
hopes of keeping its viewers stuck to
their seats nichijou has none of these
it's a slice-of-life anime that takes
pride in its simplicity and
outrageousness but it more than makes up
for it with fun characters a lack of
restraint when it comes to creativity
and sheer silliness that's sure to get a
few chuckles out of you it's a show
solely designed to make you laugh
because it's absurd and that isn't a bad
thing at all
[Music]
[Music]
watch out our fourth ranked school
comedy anime is prison school prison
schools the story of five boys who enter
a prestigious all-girls school thanks to
a change in the school's rules while
that may be a dream come true for some
the girls in the Academy shun them for
some strange reason they're rough
welcome continues as they get caught
peeping and are sentenced to jail in a
giant prison conveniently placed in the
campus the boys bonds will be tested as
they undergo a torturous rehabilitation
program at the hands of the underground
student council now the cool thing about
prison school is that it's a rarity
among school comedies with its plethora
of edgy scenes comedy based on
overreactions and awkward situations and
intricate mysteries this certainly isn't
a show for someone looking for a safe
light-hearted foray into high school
life but it can certainly claim through
one of the few recent school comedies to
blend those serious and non serious
elements together so well now it may be
a different blend of the same see but
for those that fit snugly into its
target demographic prison schools none
of the less one of the funnier comedies
to come out in recent years
as we approach the top three here's a
look at daily lives of high-school boys
daily lives of high-school boys is
exactly what the title says daily life
of high school boys the story follows
the various misadventures of three high
school boys as they go on their
hilarious routines no day is boring with
these three around
I think the daily lives of high-school
boys is more than just a gender flipped
version of the usual cute girls doing
cute things shows that we've grown so
familiar with this show places huge
emphasis on comedy and it takes a
certain amount of talent to turn
otherwise mundane situations into comedy
goldmines
it even goes the extra mile with
parodies and jokes that border on
breaking the fourth wall divided into
short segments none of the episodes are
tiring to watch at all instead providing
an atmosphere that's light and simple
and conducive to quick short laughs if
you're an ardent anime watcher this show
will provide you with enough laughs and
jokes that you can relate to great
teacher onizuka proudly claims its
second-place standing on this list old
but gold that certainly summarizes
what's been one of the more enduring
school comedies throughout the years a
reformed delinquent looking for
direction in life
looks like Onizuka is a perfect
candidate for a teacher right well he
certainly thinks so he gets his wish but
with one twist he's placed in charge of
a class that seems to be hell-bent on
making his life miserable
luckily Onizuka isn't your conventional
teacher where can you expect from
someone with a background like his the
show successfully mixes is signature
style of comedy with some inspirational
messages thanks to its amazing titular
character Onizuka is by no means a saint
but despite his flaws and shortcomings
viewers learned to love him for all of
his womanizing drinking and over-the-top
antics Onizuka certainly shares some
life lessons that could move anyone who
gives this show a shot truly a great
teacher if you ask me great teacher
Onizuka is a fantastic and inspirational
anime and it's legacy after all these
years certainly speaks to that
[Music]
the very top of this list we have Kaguya
sama love is war Miyuki and Kaguya seem
to be the perfect couple once a genius
who claims to have some of the highest
grades in the country while the others
the heir of a wealthy family that owns
one of the largest companies in Japan
what seems to be a match made in heaven
is hindered by pride even if they have
feelings for one another their pride
doesn't allow them to confess their love
that's because the first one to confess
would be declared the loser putting
pride on the line the two engage in a
battle to make the other side confess
first it's a battle of wits like no
other
imagine Takagi son sets up but crank it
up to 11 and we have Kaguya sama love is
war essentially we have two son Dre's
falling in love with one another but
they're also geniuses who'd rather die
than allow themselves to lose we have
high-level plotting courtesy of our main
characters taking the place of the usual
goofy comedy present in shows of this
genre of course that isn't all's other
characters such as chika add more
dimension to what's already an
interesting center for 12 episodes of
great entertainment there's a reason why
this show ended up becoming one of the
most popular shows in winter 2019 and
the number one show on this list with
that we end this list it turns out
school anime comes in all forms right
there really is something for everyone
so if you have another show that you
want to recommend feel free to let your
voices be heard in the comments section
perhaps there's another hidden gem that
I forgot to include on the list and if
so I'd love to hear from you about it if
you enjoyed the video and liked my
recommendations hit the like and
notification bell button so that you
never miss videos like these don't
forget to check out our sponsors game
raid Shadow legends links in the
description I'll see you next time on
Vinnie tube
[Music]
you